y comida épica es un productor de
sandwiches en competencia perfecta que
maximiza su ganancia y contrata
trabajadores en un mercado de trabajo en
competencia perfecta dibuja gráficas
lado a lado del mercado de trabajo y de
comida épica que muestre lo siguiente
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
antes de que lo resolvamos juntos vamos
a resolverlo nos piden dibujar gráficas
lado a lado una para el mercado y otra
para comida épica aquí dibujo la gráfica
del mercado en el eje horizontal está la
cantidad de trabajo y en el eje vertical
está el salario que es el precio del
trabajo
esta es la gráfica del mercado y aquí
dibujo lado a lado la gráfica de la
empresa de nuevo en el eje horizontal
está la cantidad de trabajo y acá está
el salario es la gráfica de comida épica
a nivel de empresa ahora nos piden el
salario del mercado y la cantidad de
trabajadores contratados en el mercado
para hacerlo tenemos que pensar en la
demanda de trabajadores en el mercado
cuando los salarios son altos no habrá
cantidad de trabajo demandado y conforme
disminuyen los salarios más personas
querrán contratar a otras personas
esta es la curva de demanda del mercado
de trabajo y la curva de oferta va a
tener una pendiente ascendente cuando
los salarios son bajos pocas personas
querrán trabajar en ellos pero conforme
los salarios aumentan más personas
querrán ser parte de esta fuerza de
trabajo
esta es la curva de oferta del mercado
de trabajo
y nos piden el salario de equilibrio que
debe etiquetarse como w sub m que está
por acá wv sub m y la cantidad de
trabajadores contratados en el mercado
está aquí de sub m así que ya resolvimos
este inciso que es la parte que se
enfoca en el mercado ahora nos piden la
curva de costo marginal del factor con
etiqueta cmg efe esto es lo que va a
costarle a comida épica el contratar
trabajadores pues dice que está en un
mercado de competencia perfecta se va a
pagar el salario del mercado vamos a
señalarlo es el precio que se paga por
el trabajo que es la curva de costo
marginal del factor y así resolvimos
este inciso la curva del ingreso
marginal del producto etiquetado y mgp
la forma en que resolvemos esto
típicamente es que para comida épica hay
un ingreso marginal del producto para
cierta cantidad de trabajadores y
conforme contratan a más personas
disminuyen los rendimientos por lo que
una curva típica de ingreso marginal del
producto luce
ya resolvimos este inciso el salario
pagado por la empresa etiquetado w
y la cantidad de trabajadores
contratados por la empresa etiquetado te
sube el salario que debe pagar la
empresa es dictado por el salario del
mercado por lo que podemos decir que
esto es igual al salario del mercado y
es igual al salario de la empresa por lo
que lo ponemos aquí ya resolvimos esta
parte y ahora veamos la cantidad de
trabajadores contratados por la empresa
los racionales que se contrate gente
hasta que la curva de ingreso marginal
del producto sea mayor que la del costo
marginal al contratar esa unidad
adicional de trabajo que iguala el
ingreso y el costo marginal es justo en
este punto de intersección la cantidad
de trabajadores contratados por la
empresa t sub y resolvamos la siguiente
pregunta ahora nos dicen supón que hay
un aumento en el precio de los
sandwiches de comida épica a corto plazo
los salarios pagados por comida épica
serán mayores o menores
o iguales a w sub
explica pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolver lo bueno a corto plazo no
importa cuánto contraté o no esta
empresa va a tener que pagar el mismo
sueldo por lo que va a ser igual a w sub
así que paga igual que w sube porque
opera en un mercado de trabajo de
competencia perfecta
ahora nos dicen a corto plazo qué pasará
con el número de trabajadores
contratados por comida épica explica a
corto plazo si los salarios son los
mismos pero tuvieron un aumento en el
precio de los sandwiches entonces
significa que el ingreso marginal del
producto se va a desplazar a la derecha
porque podrán vender por más cada unidad
así que tenemos que esta curva se
desplaza a la derecha por lo que tenemos
y mgp 2 después del aumento de precio
noten que ahora esta curva inter seca a
la recta de cmg efe en un punto más alto
así que qué va a pasar con el número de
trabajadores contratados el número de
trabajadores va a aumentar porque y mgp
se desplaza a la derecha debido al
aumento de precio lo que hace
que la curva de costo marginal del
producto en una cantidad mayor de
trabajo muy bien resolvamos el inciso c
comida épica usa trabajo y capital en la
producción de los sandwiches el producto
marginal de la última unidad de capital
usada es de 4000 unidades y el producto
marginal de la última unidad de trabajo
usada es 3000 si comida épica minimiza
costos y la renta del capital es 400
cuál es el salario pausa en el vídeo y
vean si pueden resolverlo
nos dicen algunas cosas que el producto
marginal de la última unidad de capital
aquí uso acá como capital para no
confundirnos con otra cosa aunque
podrían decir que deberíamos usarse pero
es mejor evitar confusiones así que el
producto marginal de la última unidad de
capital es de 4000 unidades
sabemos que el producto marginal de la
última unidad de trabajo es 3000
unidades y podemos ver la tasa de renta
del capital
que podemos ver como el precio del
capital o el costo marginal del factor
del capital o sea el precio del capital
es igual a 400 pesos y nos piden
calcular el salario que podemos ver como
el precio del trabajo a que es igual y
nos dicen que minimizan los costos una
forma de pensar en ello es el número de
unidades producidas por cada peso que
obtiene la empresa es decir si pueden
obtener más unidades producidas por cada
peso agregando un peso extra en trabajo
en lugar de gastarlo en capital o
gastarlo en capital en lugar de gastarlo
en trabajo así lo harán vamos a suponer
que el número de unidades producidas por
peso que la empresa obtiene en este
punto serán las mismas sin importar si
gastan en trabajo o en capital por lo
que el número de unidades producidas por
peso que obtienen del capital es el
producto marginal del capital dividido
entre el precio del capital este es el
número de unidades por peso y esto tiene
que ser igual al número de unidades
producidas por peso que obtienen de la
última unidad de trabajo es el producto
marginal del trabajo
las unidades producidas que obtienen del
trabajo dividido entre el precio del
trabajo en el mercado y luego despejamos
esto esto será cuatro mil unidades
divididas entre 400 pesos que es igual a
3 mil unidades divididas entre el precio
del trabajo podemos manipular un poco
esto hagamos un poco de espacio podemos
dividir ambos lados entre 400 por lo que
esto es igual a 10 unidades por peso
aquí hay 10 unidades por peso que es
igual a 3 mil unidades entre el precio
del trabajo seguimos manipulando esto
multiplicando ambos lados entre el
precio del trabajo y dividiendo a ambos
lados entre 10 con un poco de álgebra
nos da 300 pesos por el costo adicional
de trabajo
el precio del trabajo que es igual a 300
pesos pueden verificarlo sustituyendo
los números si quieren y con esto
terminamos